et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis atlanta aux etats-unis avec ben
swan journaliste d'investigation c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir bonne foi de merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ft france alors la
requalification en meurtre à ce qu'elle
peut apaiser les esprits il semblerait
que la nuit a déjà été un petit peu plus
calme la nuit dernière dans qu'aux états
unis
effectivement la lutte est plus calme
mais ne sommes pas encore arrivés au
bout beaucoup d'énergie sans vous les
deux choses effectivement une
requalification en meurtre est également
que les autres agents de police qui se
trouvait sur place soit également accusé
et c'est également arriver les
manifestations en cours dure en fait
depuis plusieurs années pour lutter
contre la vie des noirs et il s'agit de
problèmes beaucoup plus large que ce
cas-ci donc des manifestants et des
militants de travail très dur afin de
mettre en place des changements
systémiques donc peut-être qu'il y aura
une accalmie mais en tout cas cette
dynamique je pense qu'ils ne vont pas
essayer de la perdre est ce que
justement vous sentez un changement est
ce qu'on est à un tournant aux états
unis on sait qu'il ya toujours eu voilà
ce racisme en créant tout cas c'est ce
que plusieurs dénoncent notamment l'onu
qu'ils ont aimé les michael jordan le
basketteur est ce qu on est quand même
en train de changer les choses aux
etats-unis est-ce qu'il ya une prise de
conscience
je pense effectivement qu'il ya une
prise de conscience
c'est un moment historique rien ne se
passe rapidement en matière de
changements sociaux
beaucoup de personnes notamment dans les
autres pays pourrait se dire eh bien
c'est un problème qui existe depuis
longtemps et maintenant seulement
arriverez le changement
mais effectivement cela fait longtemps
qu'il ya des appels pour le changement
au moins cinq ans pour ses
manifestations des black light matin
donc il y a eu une pression qui dure
déjà depuis longtemps et nous arrivons à
un moment pivot
les choses doivent arriver et il doit y
avoir des changements alors le monde a
également réagi l'onu parlé de bide
screamin à sion raciale la chine a
accusé les états unis
voilà de racisme persiste en ce soir un
gala merkel a accusé a dénoncé ce
meurtre raciste comment réagit-on entre
guillemets à ces réactions de
l'extérieur aux états unis il se passe
tellement de choses dans les rues des
grandes villes
quasiment toutes les grandes villes des
états unis il ya tant de manifestations
tant d'émeutes dans tant de villes la
plupart des américains n'ont même pas
vraiment conscience du point de vue
international parce qu il se passe
tellement choses sur notre propre sol et
il ya également encore beaucoup de
divisions au sein entre les manifestants
et la police mais également au sein des
classes politiques
donc ce que l'onu à dire ou la chine peu
de personnes s'y intéresse parce que il
se passe des choses très intense au paix
dans le pays alors ils seront peut-être
plus intéressés des américains par
donald trump qui effectivement ne joue
pas vraiment un rôle apaisant dans cette
histoire donald trump qui je vous pose
justement la question ne se trouve-t-il
pas un petit peu isolé l'armée voilà
s'est prononcé contre ses envies de
déployer l'armée dans les rues
c'est assez rare quand même
effectivement c'est rare et ce n'est pas
censé arriver du tout d'ailleurs aux
états unis cela pose de très grandes
questions
dans notre pays on a une loi qui
s'appelle qui permet au président de
déployer l'armée si le doigt afin
d'étouffer une insurrection justement et
le président a effectivement évoqué
cette possibilité
puis beaucoup mais beaucoup de personnes
remettent en question s'il devrait avoir
le droit s'il le peut la plupart des
experts disent qu'il le pourrait mais ce
serait une très mauvaise idée est très
mal pour le pays lorsqu on déploie
l'armée pour arrêter des manifestations
on passe dans un système tout à fait
différent normalement ce sont les
gouverneurs qui doivent déployer la
garde nationale jamais l'armée
nous avons des lignes très claire dans
ce pays entre l'utilisation de l'armé et
l'utilisation de la police domestique
le président semble être en train de
flouter ces lignes et c'est très
frustrant pour beaucoup de personnes
alors il n'y a pas que l'armée qui se
rebiffe un la guerre semble un petit peu
déclaré aussi avec les réseaux sociaux
dernier en date
snap chatte qui accuse donald trump de
diffuser des messages qui incitent à la
violence raciale ça aussi c'est pas
anodin
effectivement c'est très intéressant
il se passe quelque chose avec twitter
snap chatte et facebook toutes ces
grandes entreprises se battent contre le
président parce que notamment twitter à
étiqueter certains certaines des
déclarations de donald trump comme étant
en ans on gère les entreprises à des
réseaux sociaux ne peuvent pas la cible
de poursuites judiciaires
des messages et existe sur la plateforme
mais il semblerait maintenant que cela
va changer et notre homme souhaite les
retirer cette protection
s'il retire cette protection alors cela
nuira beaucoup à ces entreprises donc
effectivement il ya une guerre entre le
président et beaucoup de ces grandes
entreprises comme twitter et snap chatte
propos de commentaires du président
concernant des tirs contre des pilleurs
donc il y a effectivement une lutte
telle qu'on ne l'a jamais vu donald
trump qui en ce mettant à du côté de
l'ordre évidemment parle à son électorat
on peut quand même se poser la question
parce qu'il n'a pèse pas vraiment il ne
nous n'y fit pas il divise plutôt
comment on va peser cette dernière
séquence dans la campagne présidentielle
cette campagne sera historique 2020 a
été l'année la plus incroyable de
l'histoire moderne en matière de
rebondissements et nous sommes qu'en
juin la cambre effectivement on l'a déjà
évoqué la campagne n'a pas encore
commencé on pensait qu'elle commencerait
avec la fin de la crise du coronavirus
mais on n'a même pas l'impression d'être
en période de campagne avec tous les
événements donc il sera très intéressant
de voir la façon dont de notre homme va
essayer de tourner la situation
en tout cas son taux d'approbation est
le plus bas que jamais eu aucun
président américain de l'histoire
moderne
merci ben swan avoir été en direct avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
merci à vous